[Applaudissements]
merci merci
c'est bon c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
Corse mais là vraiment devinez doucement
quand vous avez vous avez vous avez
épousé Fatou vous allez donc dansé au
mariage et comment réagit la belle
famille en vous voyant danser
difficilement ah oui j'imagine
oui allez alors on va passer à
monsieur monsieur Jean-Michel maire
alors
Jean-Michel a marié sa fille
en juillet en juillet faire le tour du
monde en guise de voyage neuf
sympathique il est parti avec sa chérie
je me doutais franchement de vous à moi
je m'en doutais un petit peu économisés
faites quelque chose
alors vous dansez avec Isabelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Isabelle Isabelle
[Applaudissements]
j'ai récupéré votre bouchon de canne à
pêche
beaucoup
ambulateur
on est loin du déambulateur on est
proche de l'asile
fin de soirée
Béatrice vous dansez avec qui avec
Maxime
mettez-vous bien au milieu au milieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah pas mal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
franchement
c'est le mieux
ils ont bossé une chorégraphie ça
rappelait ça rappelait la pauvre et le
néanmoins très jolie je ne travaille
John Travolta non
c'était pas mal
alors pour une fois comme suis je suis
déçu en bien voilà vraiment c'est le
meilleur duo alors vous moi mais non non
bravo
[Applaudissements]
un des principes de l'émission je vous
rappelle que quand on la prépare un
minimum là mais moi j'avais dit la
chenille alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
désolé merci
[Applaudissements]
je dois dire je dois dire que j'avais
pas bien compris la question je croyais
que c'était calé de votre chanson
préférée dans un mariage déjà un mariage
ça me fait flipper pourquoi
je marierai jamais c'est la chenille je
trouve ça tellement partir
les mariages des anciens connus
vous avez vu assister
je n'ai rien compris comme d'habitude
[Rires]
donc il fallait bien yes
de Johnny avec Adeline non ah non non
pas du tout
il y avait Johnny qui était le
très grand
[Musique]
il y avait Johnny qui était qui était le
fait de témoin ah voilà c'est bien
pourquoi vous voyez
là
j'ai pas vu à manos ah là si je suis
allé au mariage de Charles de Turckheim
alors là alors vraiment Gilles alors
d'abord c'est une amie c'est une
brillante comédienne
et voilà alors je retire très bien
allez-y Monsieur Tout à fait d'accord et
quel est le thème parce que est-ce que
vous avez est-ce que vous avez compris
la séquence
à tango non pas du tout c'est pas du
tout attendu force deviner ce que c'est
la musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas mal non c'est bien ça c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
il est bien dans son corps pour la
prochaine pour la prochaine bah moi
normalement enfin sauf si vous voulez
pas que je participe à l'émission alors
comme je comme je vous sentez pas à fond
sur la séquence Géraldine vu que vous
avez fait la chemise qui déjà pour moi
était un événement
historique parce que vous la jeunesse
est quand même le grand écart c'est la
rencontre de la c'est un peu la
rencontre de la carte du lapin parce que
voilà parce que ça marche
ça vous évite ça vous évite de repasser
voilà donc je vous ai épinglé mais de
rien c'est ça me fait plaisir alors je
fais le lien Zorba le Grec oui
et vous l'avez croisé non parce qu'en
fait on s'est le moment où je suis
rentré à Paris lui arriver à Mykonos on
s'est donné le relais ah très bien et
voilà elle est au Rambo aussi oui tout à
fait j'ai passé beaucoup de temps en
robot normal c'est la base merci
beaucoup